[Music]
alright guys we are on location this
week and joining me I'm going to look
down here because you've got a great bio
here is a former design ethicist at
Google who now leads time well-spent
which is a really great organization
trying to figure out how do we be couple
the madness of the internet and our
brain you can use that line if you want
Tristana hours welcome to the Rubin
report thanks for having me I'm really
looking forward to this yeah because
although we're going to do a little
politics that's really not what we're
doing here we're going to be talking
about I went into my pocket to find my
phone they took it from me thank God
they took it from me so that we can
actually have a conversation for an hour
you're basically talking about the way
that our phones and Technology and the
algorithms and the constant social media
on plug all of this stuff is changing us
yeah is that a fair estimation to kick
this thing off yeah well I spent before
leaving Google I spent about three and a
half years studying design ethics which
is really there was really no field for
it but basically how do you essica least
ear what a billion people are going to
think feel and do if you are in the
control room at a big tech company like
Facebook mostly but also Google and
Apple in shaping the you know the home
screens and the notifications of what
will be the constraints of how a billion
people's lives are steered today yes so
design a thesis so that's that's the
physical stuff mostly right so that's
not we're going to get into some of the
sort of mental stuff and and push
notifications and how all that stuff
affect us but at first this was really
about like the physical portion of
actually know more than screen so more
the way that you know if facebook puts a
variable schedule reward like the little
red notification thing you know what's
the ethics of that because well I they
like the physical locations and things
like that
yeah more than just the way that the
information is just slamming as always
Oh totally yeah but really the fold the
full stack of it I think this whole rear
persuadable at every single level from
the attentional level of the trust level
to the belief level yeah and so how do
you steer the phenomenology
of someone yeah so how do we how do we
do that like so you guys sit down you
get this job what are you looking at are
you looking at a phone at first like how
how does it all go well so at the time I
was on the Gmail team and I was
interested in first of all that as
you're designing the next version of
Gmail became inbox a lot people have
inbox now how do you for example decide
should you buzz people's pockets when
they get a new email so it's like a
seemingly trivial right decision but you
know whether you decide one way or the
other
like dinner conversations and families
will either be disrupted or not and
really will glance and then see it and
then get sucked in or not all because of
this one decision in California with a
handful of people in a room right so how
does that go down how does that
discussion even happen um well so at the
time I wasn't a design editors I was
just working on Gmail with that team and
I got really interested in the way that
people were talking in that meeting
which was more about the engagement of
the app how do we build a successful
apps button delightful to use that
people like to use and none of it was
kind of anchored on how do we know
whether or not this is actually a net
positive experience at all on people's
lives right like it's you take a step
back in u.s. when is email actually
making life better right like like this
sort of the deeper underlying like if
you didn't have email at all would your
life be worse or would it just be like
would it be a lot better so so instead
of saying how do you my answer for that
to the end I'll give all my feelings of
it oh yeah no I mean I saw because it
started for me having my own questions
about you know being bombarded in a big
company with just email onslaught every
day and Google Calendar invites and you
just kind of ask like man when are we
actually doing work like when is this
what am I getting emails or responding
to things that lead to something what
when is this action when is what is this
just filling up our lives with with
noise and it's it's really subtle to ask
like where are those net positive took
to life and so it started off just with
my own kind of frustration with with
technology and email and then realizing
that that conversation with this team of
people who are going to influence what a
hundred million knowledge
workers do a lot of people you know live
their whole day outside of email like
that's like what they do that the Gmail
box was just there yeah
and they they lived there like that's
where their attention is like they
living inside it and so I made this
presentation at Google called a call to
minimize distraction and respect
people's attention and it was sort of a
manifesto as I was planning to leave and
ended up going viral to thousands of
thousands of people at Google and I
ended up you know sort of in the self
titled role of how do you ethically
design stuff yeah so you're planning to
leave you do this it takes off and then
it was sort of like a relief to people
because did you sense that a lot of
people were feeling this I've been
talking about this on and off for about
two years about my exhaustion with some
of the stuff and why I need to shut down
and not look at my feet all the time and
all this stuff and yeah you'd like to
you'd probably be happy to know that I
tried twice a year for a week to lock my
phone in the safe oh yeah and not do
anything I tried try outfit is the
operative word yeah but once you sort of
went public with this did you find that
there was like just this massive need
for it
well first was just in google because
this presentation was definitely within
you know at Google and it was more
talking to the designers about our
responsibilities and shaping other
people's attention and whether they were
stressed out so their response was was
pretty remarkable I mean I sent it to
only about ten people for feedback and
the next thing when I came to work I had
you know 15 emails and when I clicked on
the presentation it shows you the number
of people looking at it once and there
was a hundred and fifty simultaneous
Googlers looking at at the same time so
I knew it it started spreading virally
and when I went to the bus the next day
there was like 500 people sick it struck
a chord within Google and you know I
think I think it struck a chord in a way
that people knew is a problem in their
own lives but I think it had not been
brought up that we were responsible
because really you know this whole
narrative that it's up to us to choose
how we use technology and how many
emails we send and what we post on
Facebook and I was really challenging
that yeah how does a company like Google
feel about having that challenge well I
think that um it's interesting case
throughout Silicon Valley in general
it's a totally libertarian culture
then you know from the top down people
made their millions by their own
self-will and their own success of the
companies and therefore it's always
people's individual responsibility with
how they use everything but what this
missed was that in the race for
attention every single app or media site
or new site or podcast is competing for
attention and the best way to do that is
to actually play these sort of magic
tricks on people's minds and do
manipulate them so you can get as much
attention as possible
yeah and that that element is where the
responsibility lies yeah it's
interesting you said magic trick because
you used to be into magic as a kid right
yeah you sort of knew what some of these
tricks are so what are some of the
tricks that are keeping us looking at
these things all day
well the main one I say all the time is
just that your phone is basically a slot
machine because everything will time you
check it you either got invited to do
the Reuben report or you just get
another newsletter we were going to send
you a regular mail something but it
seems you know not very 27p yeah right
right but it's because of the fact that
when you turn your phone over it could
be a match on tinder with that hot
whatever that you want to date it could
be the email that's really exciting it
could be the text message from that
person you really wanted to text you or
it could just be nothing literally it's
like a slot machine you're every single
time you turned over you're playing yeah
and then sometimes you get good stuff
and if you don't trump's kind of like a
negative slot machine where you play a
be like what happened to you know
damage report kind of yeah how much of
that is making us crazy to be saying
because i've noticed just in the last
couple weeks I've been traveling a lot
and you know when you're sitting there
someone on a plane you sort of end up
looking at what they're doing no matter
like just even if you're not trying to
like you know end up seeing a little
thing whether it's reading the paper or
whatever but I've noticed a lot of times
people are on Facebook just scrolling
right and their feeds are completely
insane yeah you see a picture of a baby
then you see Trump might start war with
North Korea right then you see a cat
video yeah and then you see a baseball
game and it's like this information for
our brain no yeah can you talk about
that a little bit well yeah in so many
levels
I mean Neil postman is actually the best
sort of thinker on these topics he wrote
a book in 1982 called amusing ourselves
you know his
uh I know of the book yeah yeah just
just really how media like but what does
it do to a human being like the human
animal animal to sort of stick these
like one at a time off totally unrelated
sound bites and he was like men in TV
when there's these sort of now this and
then now this on TV where you go from
the car accident in your local town to
North Korea and then and now this and
here's like a little clown dancing or
something in a funny way
right and just what that does to people
taking seriously something right now
we're very nostalgic for that the idea I
don't really watch local news but the
idea of just like basic local news seems
pretty sane relative to what's going on
on most people's feeds these days yeah
yeah exactly
it's it's all over the place happy of
driving people crazy yeah so what do we
do what what do we do what have you
found that we can do to uncouple some of
this stuff from from making us nuts well
I mean one is for what I try to do is go
out there and clarify what exactly is
the problem so what people miss is we
always think like technologies tool and
we could use it in any way and it's
evolving in this sort of open and do it
went in it away we could have VR and
augmented reality and look at all these
amazing possibilities that could be and
I actually want to say like that is not
true we know exactly where this is going
and the reason we know exactly where
it's going is because every technology
company and every app and every news
website and every whatever has to
compete for attention can you be a
politician
and not get attention to win an election
no can you be a podcast and not get
attention to to you don't be successful
no everyone even a meditation app has to
fit your attention right and so you just
think of the city and we only have so
much it's a zero-sum game so if I spend
it like editing typos on my last
Facebook posts and like saying I gotta
make sure I fix those I'm not spending
it with my friend or I'm not reading the
news or I'm not seeing the cat photos so
we have to ask this question of what is
worthy of our attention what's worthy of
our time that's what the first time well
spent comes from yeah and so that means
if you're if you're a technology
designer what stuff do you put into this
limited time block you're inserting into
someone's life like
what should be there because they're not
going to choose this they see themselves
choosing but they're choosing from a
menu that you write up in the first
place right so as you said though since
Silicon Valley is a pretty libertarian
place where everyone's trying to figure
out the next mousetrap and all that
right isn't scaling back some of this
stuff while it might be mentally healthy
I actually I'll take my doubt while I'm
sure it's mentally healthy for all of us
it's sort of counterintuitive to how
these businesses operate right they need
you to use it as much as possible yeah
because there's anyone evil there I just
as a classic like you know they make
more money the more time you're on the
feed there might be someone evil there
but that's not the general some of them
do go to the race to the bottom of the
brainstem and the question if you go
really low on the brainstem that can be
kind of evil snapchat does a couple
things there yeah so what's something
like that I do think that sort of tiered
thing is interesting yeah I mean I think
this is really interesting if you say
there's like a Geneva Convention of
persuasion right saying well how low in
the brainstem should we be allowed to go
so one thing that snapchat does
particularly and I find this
particularly concerning because the
number one use case or demographic is
teenagers using them and kids so there's
a persuasive technique where if you put
people into a reciprocity relationship
where they kind of owe each other
something so if your friend says happy
birthday to you say oh thank you so much
right but if you were able to be like
puppet master above two people and tap
this one on the shoulder and get them to
say happy birthday to this person and
every single time they had to respond to
happy birthday they have to go back into
Facebook mm-hmm then you're sitting
there causing all these people to do all
these things and run around like
chickens with their heads cut off yeah
and it might be beneficial but it also
might be manipulative so what snapchat
does is they invented a feature called
streaks that shows the number of days in
a row that you sent a message back and
forth and so if you're a kid you have
like thirty of these things going it's
like for example say you have 150 days
going with this friend and what they
just did is they invented something but
now these two kids don't want to lose
mm-hmm and so it's not even that they're
having real conversations with each
other they're going just to make it
through their day they have to send a
message of a photo or a wall or anything
just to sort of tap the other friend in
the shoulder and they have to send a
message back yeah and kids when they go
on vacation they give their password to
five other
friends to make sure they don't lose
their streak so all of this this is
getting sort of added to the little
scheduling little blocks of time in kids
minds in their lives mm-hmm and it's
it's not done because it's helping then
live their life right done because it's
really good at getting you to say and
addicted to the app right so if you were
sitting down with the snapchat people
yeah and they heard you say this I
suspect they would basically be like
yeah we just want engagement and you
know we don't deny what you're saying is
what we're doing this maybe they'd
subtly deny it or something but if you
actually be really I'm really interested
in denial I spent the whole summer
studying denial actually and I think
it's it's there's so many different
excuses right like one is well if we
don't do it someone else will another
one is well people like it I'm sure I
can point I'm sure there's like some
story somewhere in the world where two
kids had some like really hilarious
life-changing positive effect right the
11 streaks like that anecdote exist
somewhere right but the question is you
know for each of these things like yeah
I think I think there isn't enough of an
ethics conversation about these things
that actually what I found in my work is
there's there is no understanding of
what ethical persuasion is it's a very
very deep like multifaceted there's a
lotta different moral variables inside
of what would be an ethical or unethical
persuasion transaction yeah all right
well let's talk about some ethical
transactions and so would you say that's
unethical what they're doing but by the
definitions of what you would say is
ethical is that sort of low-hanging
fruit just keep them doing nonsense
would you say that is unethical in it I
would say that specific design technique
with that audience is not is not okay
yeah the reason is because so here's
another defense I would use if I were
snapchat yeah well it's just a product
you can choose to use the product or you
cannot use the product right now or you
could say you know if you're having
trouble with it it's like it's just a
number like just ignore the number it's
not like we're forcing you to do with no
right right but what this misses is of
course that we are persuadable like we
don't walk around with that the
libertarian instinct is we don't walk
around with an idea that people can like
pull on a little part of our minds right
but when you have that number there and
especially this is woman Emily wines and
Harvard who studied all this and that's
where this research comes from she found
specifically like developmentally
challenged
or like the ones who are younger still
figuring out their self-worth and
identity that they're the ones most
prone to needing to keep up these
streaks because they feel like their
friendship is tied up in whether or not
they continue it so one thing that makes
this unethical is that because snapchat
is the number one predominant way for
these kids to communicate this is like
for you and I what text messaging is
right so imagine like build into opening
your mouth to talk to anybody
is this manipulative techniques you
can't open your mouth without being
exposed to this persuasive draw yeah and
so that's it's sort of like it's
building it too close to a core
dimension of communication right that's
one aspect second is the developmental
one that they're young they don't know
this is happening the goals of the
persuaders are not transparent to the
persuade D's there's a whole long list
of their dimensions of what makes it
okay or not right so before we get into
the ethical part I would imagine some
people would hear this and say well you
know what this is the parents fault you
can't stop the companies right if you're
going on the libertarian route you can't
stop the companies from doing it right
and they're putting all these things no
one's force you need to do it like I can
buy all that stuff the other brands item
we can fully buy all that stuff right
but you know I see all the time now
three year old kids at restaurants iPad
they can't even talk yet they don't even
they don't even realize what's real and
not real so some of it you would just
say is just a parental thing right like
that's just a piece of this too right
well I mean absolutely there there has
to be a question that went how early you
expose kids to screens and that's a
question that the parents have but I
mean this is for snapchat it's a lot of
teenagers yeah and their social identity
and their social opportunities their
sexual opportunities all of that stuff
is wrapped up in the side of one medium
because that's the dominant way that
everybody else is talking and they're
not talking of any other medium like you
can't talk to them you probably included
so it's like it's the only way to get
invited to the party is to be on
snapchat that's the trade I would have
to make and that's what makes it kind of
like a cult like I've studied cult quite
a bit and cults are interesting because
they persuade not just the individual
but your sort of social findings with
everybody else yeah so what are okay so
that was sort of a low grade one that's
happening yeah could question it the s
the ethnicity that one
ya think so the ethics oh yeah okay the
ethics of what what are some sort of
mid-level ones that maybe aren't so low
hanging fruit that are out there um well
like you know variable schedule Awards
so very look at rewards is that slot
machine of mechanics right so like is
that so bad well I mean what it does is
when the more I expose you to you pull a
lever and sometimes you have unis go to
Twitter you know load Twitter and
there's like a five-second delay where
puts the number of new notifications yet
everything I've been on there once or
twice yeah not proud I'm not proud of
what I know I love Twitter well I'm glad
you brought up cuz I love Twitter I
built so much my audience I love
interacting with people on there but
I've grown it to a point where now it's
like it's just such a cacophony of
insanity on hearing and and some I could
get a hundred positive things and they
mean nothing and then one person is like
[ __ ] do Arobin and them and then of
course that's the one that I pay
attention to right which probably has a
lot to do with the way they've designed
this thing yeah well you know that's
what's so tricky else about these things
is in talking about or criticizing the
manipulative aspects it's not like we
don't derive benefit from writers or
they unleashed whole new amazing new
social relationships or people eating
each other they would have never met
that's all great questions could you get
to similar places of benefits while
cutting out all the bad stuff yeah so so
but take this example of Twitter so they
have this slot machine leg thing when
you load the page it doesn't just show
you immediately the number it shows you
after this extra delay you'll notice you
load the page there's like a couple
extra seconds and then the number goes
up like that and that delay is what
makes it a little bit more addictive so
what it's doing is it's talking to a
totally unconscious part of your mind
and inserting essentially a habit which
like now you're going to feel compelled
to want to check it again like on your
next break Bay right because you're a
junior play map machine
so what could they do differently well
they could actually say what would be
time well spent for you using Twitter
and you'd be like look I just want to
know like once a week the most important
people who didn't just retweet stuff
that I've done yeah but who said
something to me and the people who have
more than like I don't know but of 5,000
followers or something like that any
time most men
and so you could imagine there's a
version of Twitter be very easy for them
to do that where it doesn't show you
between now and then all of these sort
of variable rewards it just delivers at
the end of the week there's one batch
yeah and so that makes it less addictive
but also still delivers all the benefits
and so that creates a timeline that
would be instead of like six choppy uses
of it you get one big organized use of
it yeah so I think that's kind of like
rearranging your open plan of a city but
it's the city of the attention economy
so what's what's a vert incentive to do
that if if basically we know that you
know when they're selling ads or
whatever however if they're making money
and they're looking at shareholders and
all that and they're they're not doing
that well Twitter obviously right but
like what's their incentive when they
just want you on there right or is there
no incentive and you're just trying to
flat out just be like this is how time
well-spent should be spent so there's no
incentive for them to change this that's
that's exactly the problem that is it's
this race to the bottom
that's not competing for like what we
would want Twitter to be competing for
which is the benefit that it delivers
neuralyzed it's competing for whatever
the next micro dose of like a tension it
can kind of pull from you I think of
this like so I mean they're not going to
change base until their business model
is not advertising right so so one of
the things that I said this on Sam's
podcast too is we have to be able to
decouple the relationship between more
of the time I steal from you
equals more money I make and this is
actually not different from what
happened in energy utilities where at
first they make more money the more
energy you use so like you know just
like I actually have an incentive like
going to your house like flipped all the
profits on it leave the lights on and
like not tell you to turn anything off
and to waste as much energy as possible
it'd be good for me as an energy company
right all right but then that was a
perverse incentive so they established
this utility commission board that
basically sets targets that
disincentivizes you from using what
really makes that when you go beyond a
certain tier it's more expensive right
and then they don't actually get that
money it gets reinvested into more
renewable energy programs so what if
like technology companies work similarly
where up to a certain point they make
more money the more use they get beyond
a certain point it's decoupled or not
they don't make more money and all that
extra money gets pulled
directly into sort of social good
projects like imagine fighting fake news
or cyberbullying although I can get
resourced in a deliberate way yeah so I
so I like the concept behind that but do
you think that has to be done by the
government so I could when you think
about it in the context of you know
electricity or water power I see I've
hit that tier once or twice on on water
when I've had a lot of people write over
or on a gas or electricity or whatever
and then you see oh wow I went up and
then my bill actually really increased
decrease of that from it's almost it
could be a moot point to you whether
it's going to renewable energy or just
to the company or whatever right but
would you need the government to set
standards on that for a town that again
as you said is pretty libertarian yeah
well I mean that's what's tricky about
this I can't remember what energy
utilities when this happened how much of
this was an opt-in by all the utility
companies together there's sometimes
this can happen by everybody
collectively realizing there's a problem
that the threat of regulation is coming
from government and they can get ahead
of it by creating their own management
board in this case utilities are also
partially publicly owned okay it's
complicated I think there's a huge
question about governance here that tech
companies have one goal which is to
maximize shareholder value and their
shareholder value tied to maximizing how
much tension from your life if they take
yeah so that that by itself obviously
would need to be changed in some way for
us to live in a healthier world
you
[Music]